you know the main point is that
policymakers have to deal with a lot of
uncertainty and a great deal of of
developments and events that are
basically not predictable the point
about Bernanke is that it's hardly hard
to think of a central banker who was
better informed and more knowledgeable
of the problems that of the Great
Depression he's written extensively and
had good understanding of the what was
considered to be the failures of the
central bank banks particularly in the
1930s after the depression got under
underway but in spite of that knowledge
it's very clear that the Federal Open
Market Committee under Bernanke did not
see the mortgage crisis coming they did
not see the housing crisis they were
aware that housing prices that the
housing industry was going through an
adjustment and this was repeated in the
press releases by the Federal Open
Market Committee all through 2007 if you
go through the press releases clear up
through august seven 2007 ah the
Bernanke and the committee is still has
some concern about inflation they're
holding the federal funds rate a Tyrell
of a high level at that time and they
did not anticipate the almost complete
collapse of the mortgage market in early
august two thousand and set while the
evidence that the federal reserve system
the Federal Open Market Committee and
Bernanke did not anticipate the kind of
trouble we were in has indicated by
looking at the difference between the
press release they put out in August
seventh 2007 and the 13 days later are
on August 10th on August seventh they
were reiterating there that they would
hold the of the federal funds rate
steady and I think at that time was five
and a quarter percent that and that they
still anticipated the possibility of
inflation and then three days later the
press release said point south at a
number of financial markets are likely
to experience considerable stress and
well tell me about it the mortgage
market had fallen had completely
collapsed and it was in the it was the
derivatives market that was the tip-off
you see that derivatives market was was
the kind of and its collapse was the
first indication that they that the
whole mortgage market was in was in
serious trouble and no one has I think
better expert a econometric and economic
analysis and the Federal Reserve but it
doesn't mean that they can predict what
is not predictable and and so it's it's
clear that the experts
were surprised and blindsided by that
development but I think it's super
Bernanke's credit that he moved pretty
what seemed to be like a pretty dis in a
pretty decisive way at that time to
dramatically enhance the liquidity of
the banking system the problem is that
what was happening I think in the
mortgage market indicated that what the
bank's face faced was a solvency problem
not just a liquidity problem now
sometimes of course it's hard to tell
the difference you have a solvency
problem you see if if the fundamental
value of your assets are lessened about
the value of your obligations that's
different from a liquidity problem into
in the sense that you just have a a
short-term need for for funds and of
course you can have if you have a
short-term need for funds and a lack of
liquidity that can cause distress sales
and create a solvency problem but and I
think that's the way that Bernanke saw
the situation he was in in august two
thousand seven and it's also i think
pretty much how he saw the developments
in the early 30s an early part of the
great depression that the Federal
Reserve System had simply not supplied
sufficient liquidity to keep the system
from becoming creating an insolvency
problem I don't really agree with this i
think in both cases they're both in in
1930 there's evidence that the banks had
a solvency problem because of their of
the of the loans that have been extended
on
on residential and also commercial
properties and those prices had had
started to had come down and in fact
that that had been developing for all
ready for three or four years before in
the late 1920s just as it had been
developing the defaults were starting to
move up in our economy already by two
thousand five six and seven started to
become then critical in in 2007 but I
think the point is that the point about
personal knowledge palani and also hiked
emphasizes this that there's a
difference between knowing that and
knowing how you know academic knowledge
tends to be based very much upon knowing
about things knowing being able to
analyze conditions after the fact but
but that doesn't necessarily give you
good capacity to predict in advance and
in particular it's just like those of us
that do experimental economics we
realize that and this is true gentleman
and all of experimental sciences and you
find this input on you when he talks
about personal knowledge there's a lot
of human capital involved in the
experimental sciences and this is a kind
of an operating knowledge it's a it's a
form of can-do knowledge that you learn
by being involved in doing lots of
experiments you don't learn about it by
reading about it it's like you know it's
like learning to play the piano you
don't learn to play the piano by
learning by reading about you learn by
practicing and the same thing is true
through much of the economy a lot
of the knowledge in the economy is this
kind of can-do practical knowledge
learned by practice and the same thing
is true of at the level of experts and
formula formulating central bank policy
it's a matter of practice and you can
have a good understanding of say the
1930s about what happened then but it
doesn't mean yet when you're in in the
middle of the storm you will recognize
that it's happening around you because
it's just a different kind of
understanding based upon based upon
practice and not necessarily the kind of
academic analysis and knowledge that we
get through econometric analysis and
studies and I think that's basically a
problem and it means that you shouldn't
have too high expectations as to what
the ability of our experts to deliver is
there going to be fallible and what
we've seen I think in throughout this
crisis is both in the Federal Reserve
and also in the US Treasury and other
agencies of government you've had people
learning as they go and a lot of the
policies are being made up as they go
and that's I think an inevitable
consequence of the imperfection
imperfection of our knowledge and the
limits of our ability to to practically
manage complex systems like the US the
US economy and this
and so what's important is really to
avoid these kind of crisis situations in
the first place and because they're so
far so difficult to deal with once we
get into them because if nothing else
the politics of these situations will
drive policy and that and not and the
politics is not necessarily a good
long-term economic policy and and of
course the way to have avoided this kind
of a problem in the first place was they
have better federal better
collateralization of the kinds of loans
that were being made in in the housing
market and and generally in consumer
credit markets it's not only the housing
market but it's also credit card debt
student loan debt automobile loans all
of those credit markets which ended up
being the kinds of private credit
instruments that the Federal Reserve
found itself necessary to make loans on
in 2008 ended up that the the liquidity
enhancement moves that the Federal
Reserve made in august of 2007 didn't
prevent the economy from declining and
and we had then in september-october
2008 it was necessary the Federal
Reserve felt it necessary to tune to
intervene on a far more massive scale
than they had done early earlier to
shore up not only the mortgage-backed
security market for housing but also the
market for student loans auto loans
cards and everything in order to prevent
a the banking system from what could
have been a major collapse
the main thing to do is to resurrect the
learning from the 20s and 30s and that
is that credit markets particularly
consumer credit markets need to involved
amer dot advertised loans and and
reasonable down payments so that when
when you bar borrow to buy automobiles
when you borrowed buy homes there should
be a requirement of a reasonable down
payment and amortization of those of
those loans and we got into the business
of at the particularly at the federal
level the the Community Reinvestment Act
in the 1990s became a means by which the
federal government enabled what wish to
enable people of modest means to make to
to buy a home and so as a result there
were that act created scoring system for
for private lenders whereby they if they
got good scores by aggressively more
aggressively making loans to people
whose incomes were below eighty percent
of the median those scores helped them
gave them enable them to to more easily
get approval for for making expansions
in regional
banks in these scores were used in
helping to decide whether to approve
mergers this sort of thing various
devices were used to to encourage
private lenders to more aggressively
make loans on homes to be purchased by
people of modest income and what we got
from that was a particularly strong
demand for homes at the low end of the
pricing tier and you see that in the if
you look at the case-shiller housing
index and if you divide that index into
three tiers the low-priced here the
middle priced here and the high-priced
here from 2002-2006 the the prices that
went up the most were the low-priced
here the low-priced tier of homes rose
the the most the hyatt the greatest
percentage and felled by the greatest
percentage after the collapse and so
those policies didn't actually help
those people in the sense that it ended
up in many ways we heard the people we
most had a most heartfelt desire to to
help and and the middle price to your
homes did rose less rapidly than the low
and
the higher-priced tears rose the least
so the impact of the housing bubble was
felt disproportionately in the
lower-income buyers of homes so I'm I
think I would begin not with any notion
that we need a radical a reexamination
of the regulatory framework but just
introduce some of the institutional
learning that we've already achieved and
let that institutional learning stand
and not interfere with it